[MUSIC PLAYING]
BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Welcome!
I'm Ben Frenkel.
I'm a product manager
for Google Play.
And with me today,
I'll be joined
by Jonathan Cheung, Steve Suppe,
as well as Andrew Giugliano.
And today we're
going to be talking
about unleashing the power
of Play Store Discovery.
What I wanted to
do first, though,
is get to know the
audience a little better.
I don't know all of you.
I know some of you, but
I don't know all of.
And what I wanted
to do is to see
what kind of the mix of
people are here today.
So, I want to see
a show of hands.
How many of you are on the
business side of games?
The product managers
and so forth?
All right, we've got a
decent representation there.
How many of you use the
Play Console regularly?
Either looking at reports--
All right, there's
even more hands.
And how many of
you are engineers?
How many of you
write code at least
sometimes or have
ever written code?
That might be some more hands.
Well this is a great
mix for this talk,
because we have something
for everybody today.
So for the business
side of the house,
we're going to be talking
about business impact.
What these tools can
do for your business.
We're going to show
some case studies
for the Play Console, folks.
We're going to show you how
to use the tools we're going
to be talking about today.
And for the engineers
in the room,
we have an entire
section at the end
that's a technical
deep dive into how
to use Google Play Instant.
And it even involves
actual code.
So, there's one more question,
one more exciting question.
I kind of spoil the result, but
just bear with me for a second.
I want to see one
more show of hands.
One more show of hands.
How many of you think
you've either seen
or yourself have taken
full advantage of all
the promotional tools
that Play offers?
OK, so we've got a couple of
very optimistic people here
and I love that about you.
But, the answer is, no.
None of you have really
been able to take advantage
of all of the tools that
Play provides to promote
your game on the store.
But, it's not your fault.
It's not you, it's me or us,
I should say.
Because, we haven't
really done a good job
of showing you
what it would look
like if you used all of
the tools at your disposal
to their full extent possible.
And today, we're going to close
that gap with an example led
by a good friend of mine, Burt.
This is Burt.
And through Burt's eyes
and some of his friends,
which I'll also
introduce to you,
will show you what it
would look like if you
turned all the Play's
promotional tools up to 11.
More than 10, up to 11.
This is a really big deal.
So why don't we
get things started.
We're going to start at the
beginning of Burt's journey
on the Play Store.
So Burt's the type of
person who always wants
to know what's coming next.
He loves watching trailers
of the upcoming movies.
And he gets the
same buzz when he's
looking at the pre-reg
section on the store.
So, Burt's looking at the
pre-reg section of the store.
And he spots one of his
favorite franchises, this game
SnoreCraft.
It's big on P.C. And
unaware that things
could get even
more exciting, Burt
dives into the store listing.
Wait, what's that?
He thinks There's
free stuff too?
I can unlock exclusive rewards
just by pre-registering?
And there's a demo?
I can actually play
this game right now.
I can preserve and
reserve my avatar's name.
I can customize my avatar.
And I can earn experience
points all the way up to launch.
This indeed was a
triumphant day for Burt.
Bursting with excitement, Burt
pre-registered for SnoreCraft
and shared the pre-reg listing
with almost all of his friends.
Burt slept well that night
dreaming of the rewards
he was soon to receive.
Fast forward and its launch day.
Burt wakes up, stretches,
and sees a notification
that SnoreCraft is now
available to everybody.
And before even
getting out of bed,
Burt installed SnoreCraft
and immediately
redeemed the long
awaited reward.
Boy, was Burt excited.
But this was not just
a good day for Burt.
This was also a good day for
all the people Burt invited
to the pre-registration.
And not only his friends,
but their friends, and then
their friends' friends,
and so on, and so forth,
until almost all
of Burt's friends
were playing SnoreCraft.
Almost everyone
except for the Bobs,
who I am also introducing
for the first time
here today to all of you.
So a bit of background
on the Bobs,
these are identical quadruplets
that were separated at birth.
And through a mere
quirk of fate,
they happened to
all be named Bob.
What are the chances?
And it might not be
obvious at first glance,
but when the Bobs smile, you
can really see the family
resemblance here.
So, because the Bobs missed
out on pre-registration,
the Bob's road to SnoreCraft
was different from Burt's
and Burt's friends.
Each had to chart their own
path to eventually installing
SnoreCraft.
So one Bob came through the
new and updated section.
Another was
recommended SnoreCraft.
The third Bob came through the
role-playing games collection.
Bob number four had it
suggested through ads.
And for good measure,
their cousin Becky
discovered SnoreCraft through
the editor's choice section.
But, they all eventually
landed on the store listing.
But, before we go on,
I wanted to provide
a bit of additional
context about the Bobs.
So, after they were
separated at birth,
each ended up growing up
in a different country.
One lives in Portugal.
One in Brazil.
One in Mexico.
And one lived here in
the U.S. And each of them
independently developed
an unyielding passion
for soccer, or how almost
everyone else in the world
refers to it as football.
And this context is important.
Because not only
did each of the Bobs
find their own way
to the store listing,
but when they arrived
at the store listing,
they discovered
it was customized
to their preferences.
So with an international
football event looming,
the Bob from Portugal arrived
on a store listing that
celebrated his national team.
The game icon, the
screenshots, the text,
all showed the support
for the team he loves.
The Bob from Brazil
saw a store listing
that celebrated his team.
And the Bob from Mexico and
the Bob from the U.S. store
saw store listings that
celebrated their national teams
too.
The Bobs from
Portugal and Brazil
immediately installed the
game right off the bat.
No questions asked.
However, the Bobs from
Mexico and the U.S.
were initially a
little reluctant
to install the game right away.
One Bob was concerned about the
available space on his device.
The other Bob was new to
gaming and just wasn't
familiar with the franchise.
But, fortunately, SnoreCraft
had an instant game.
The space constrained
Bob was relieved
that he could try the
game before committing
to a big install.
And the newbie,
well, though he was
unfamiliar with the
franchise, his curiosity
got the better of him.
And he clicked to try now, too.
Eventually all the
Bobs installed the game
and played happily ever after.
The end.
[APPLAUSE]
So, hopefully that's
giving you a sense of what
taking full advantage of
all the marketing tools
the Play Store
has to offer looks
like from a user's perspective.
Through Burt's eyes,
you've seen the power
of Play's pre-launch
tools, the viral growth
opportunity, the impact
of pre-reg rewards
and Google Play Instant.
And through the eyes of
all the Bobs and Becky,
you saw the impact of Play's
post-launch marketing tools,
from customized store listings
to store listing experiments.
What we're going
to do now is, we're
going to turn our attention
to what the business impact is
of these tools and the technical
details of how to use them.
When I hand things
off to Jonathan
in a second, who's
going to be talking
about the pre-launch
marketing tools.
He's going to hand
to Steve, who's
going to be talking about the
post-launch marketing tools.
And then, lastly, for the
engineers in the room,
Andrew is going to do
a deep dive into how
to build an instant game.
And with that, come on up.
Jonathan, take it away.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN CHEUNG: Thanks, Ben.
In the next section, we're going
to go over some of the tools
from the developer's
perspective.
We'll show and explain the
opportunities available for you
to use today and go
over some best practices
to make your
pre-launch campaigns as
exciting as possible.
Let's start with pre-launch.
As we all know, in the
console and P.C. world,
pre-launch marketing and even
pre-ordering has become a norm.
Well today, I'm excited to say
that pre-launch marketing is
also increasingly
popular for mobile games.
In fact, for most games, the
pre-launch and launch period
is typically the time when you
have the most buzz and interest
around your game.
Many game developers have told
us that during this period
is also the cheapest
time to acquire
a new user throughout the
lifetime of their games.
As such, it's crucial to engage
with your potential players
and hopefully capture
the interest in your game
before you launch.
So, how do you make the most
of this important period
in your game's lifecycle?
And how do you
effectively communicate
what is special about your
game and capture play interest
even before you launch?
Luckily, we at Google
Play have some tools
which can help you to grasp this
unique pre-launch opportunity.
Until recently, it has been
very difficult for developers
on Play to capture pre-launch
buzz around their games
and translate this to
actual installs at launch.
Developers had to think
very hard about where
to spend their marketing
dollars and how
to invest in different efforts,
as there is no easy way
to capture this
interest and maintain it
until the game is ready.
Well, today I'm pleased to
announce that Google Play's
pre-registration feature is
available to all developers
on Google Play.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with the tool,
pre-registration helps
capture demand generated
by pre-launch marketing.
And it activates it
at launch to help
accelerate your pre-launch
success in the market.
When your pre-registration
campaign is started,
a clear pre-registration
call to action
will appear on your
pre-release store
page, which allows users
to register interest
in your title.
In return for
pre-registering, players
will receive a launch
day notification
from Google Play allowing them
to become one of the first
to install and play your game.
Not only does it allow you to
engage and reward core fans
early, but pre-registration
notifications also
drive higher volumes
of D1 and D7 installs.
On top of this, Play's
pre-registration tool
is more effective than most when
it comes to driving conversions
to install.
On average, we actually see the
Play's pre-registration feature
sees about a 38%
conversion to install,
which is a much
higher conversion
rate versus other
pre-registration sources.
Finally, pre-registration
has the added benefit
of allowing you to display
your store listing to use this
on Play even before you launch.
This allows you to drive
traffic from all your marketing
sources to a single
destination in order
to capture launch
demand for your title.
Next, setting up a
pre-registration campaign
is super easy using
the Play Console.
First, you want to
navigate to App releases.
Then, you'll need to upload
an APK or bundle containing
a manifest describing
your device types you want
to include in your campaign.
And release it onto one of
your closed testing tracks.
Remember, you don't need to
make this closed testing track
available to any of your users.
Its purpose can be simply
to hold your APK or bundle
containing these
device restrictions.
This will in turn activate
the pre-registration control
center, which will allow you
to turn off and on countries
where you want to run your
pre-registration campaigns in.
In this control
center, you can also
see pre-registration
sign-ups per country
as well as conversions to
install per country when you
eventually launch your game.
Note that we will be limiting
pre-registration campaigns
to run for a maximum of
90 days in each country.
You will see a helpful indicator
in the console telling you when
you are close to this time.
Finally, I want to go
over some recommendations
to consider when
using pre-registration
with Google Play.
First, allow some time to
build excitement in your title.
Usually between three
to 12 weeks is ideal.
Next, use all your channels
to indicate and build interest
around your title.
You can use media, social,
YouTube, communities
with your own
website, et cetera.
And drive your Android traffic
to Play's pre-registration
on the Play Store, specifically
due to the higher conversion
rates.
So, that's Play's
pre-registration feature
in a nutshell.
But, wait, there's more.
Today, I am pleased
to announce that we
are launching pre-registration
rewards to all developers.
What does this actually
allow you to do?
Pre-registration
rewards allows you
to offer a free IAP, or in-app
purchase, to all your players
who have pre-registered
for your title.
This reward is delivered
to users via Play
and is advertised via special
card on your store listing
as you can see on the screen.
Configuring this reward is also
very easy using Play Console.
You want to select the
IAP you want to give away.
Supply the text that users
will see on your store listing
about the IAP.
And when your game
launches, this IAP
will be in the library for you
to consume in your full game
experience.
Also, remember to
configure your award
before starting your
pre-registration campaign
to ensure that all your users
will receive your reward
when you launch.
Using pre-registration
rewards is a great way
to add value to your
pre-registration campaign.
Not only does it
help incentivize uses
to pre-register for
your game, it also
can drive uplifts of
conversions to install,
as there is value
waiting for the player
when they install
and play your game.
In our pilots, we
have actually seen
about a 15% increase
in conversions
when games are using rewards.
In fact, we didn't just see
an increase in conversion,
one of our developers,
Nexon in South Korea,
also shared data showing a store
a sizable increase in uplift
and engagement for users who
received a reward versus those
who did didn't.
Players were more likely
to stick with the game
and continue actively
playing if they
received a reward at the start.
Pre-registration rewards is
available to all developers
right now to use in the
Google Play Console.
So, another new addition
to pre-registration
is the ability to
run an instant game
alongside your
pre-registration campaign.
Instant games allow you
to highlight key game play
elements of your
game and can even
display a clear call to
action to pre-register
from within the game itself.
Upload and configure
your instant game
as known on the Play Console.
And it will now show up
during pre-registration
if you distribute it
to the same countries
as you are running
your campaigns in.
This is yet another
way to add value
to pre-registration campaign.
And make it more enticing and
encourage players to finally
pre-register for your game.
It's also important to call out
that all the features we just
described can be used in
conjunction with each other
to help create a unique and
compelling pre-launch marketing
story.
For instance, you
may want to consider
tying a pre-registration
reward around a key item
or character you are showing
prominently in your marketing
material, tailor
your store listing
around your pre-registration
reward or instant game.
And you may even allow
plays to sign up and create
a character inside your instant
game, which they can then
carry over into your full
game when it launches.
We believe the intelligent
usage of these features
can help highlight
and communicate
what is special about your game,
even before the audience gets
their hands on the
finished product.
And we hope you feel inspired
to create innovative and playful
pre-launch campaigns.
Now, I'm going to
hand over to Steve,
who's going to talk about how
to effectively market your games
even after you launch.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE SUPPE: Thanks, Jonathan.
OK.
Hi, everyone.
My name's Steve.
I'm a product manager
on the Play Console.
Thanks very much
for coming today.
So, at this point,
Jonathan's just
walked you through running a
successful pre-registration
campaign.
And you've done all this work
getting ready for launch.
But once you've launched,
I'm sorry to tell you,
you're not actually finished.
You've now just opened
up the floodgates.
Your game is now exposed
to the vast demand
that Google Play brings to you.
This is scary, but
it's a good thing.
But, you have to keep optimizing
your marketing message
if you're going to make
the most of this exposure.
So, I'm going to walk you
through the key features that
will help you to do that so that
you can continuously improve
your marketing and
your acquisition rate
over the life of your launch.
When you first launch
your game on Google Play,
you'll have to design and
publish your store listing.
The store listing is your
front page for your users.
It's where users read what you
have to say about your game.
And where they can
browse your screenshots,
your trailer videos,
and hopefully
even try an instant game.
You've probably
spent weeks or even
months agonizing over the
perfect icon, screenshots,
and more, to go on this page.
And I'm sure your
teams did a great job.
But, the thing is, it's
really, really hard
to know if you've
gotten this right,
even if you think you're
getting a good conversion rate.
How do you really know
that you've optimized?
There's a lot of people out
there visiting your page.
And you'll want to
maximize your chance
of convincing them to install.
And that's why the Google Play
Console provides store listing
experiments.
Store listing experiments
is our A/B testing framework
that lets you try variants of
your store listing via properly
controlled experiments.
You can easily try new
screenshots, videos,
and descriptions,
so that you can
try all the great, and
maybe not so great,
ideas that you've ever had.
You provide the ideas.
We provide statistical
analysis so
that you can be sure that
the changes and the results
are significant.
You'll find store
listing experiments
underneath Store
presence on the left hand
nav of the Play Console.
For those of you that
are already using them,
we've introduced two
new metrics that we
think are your gold star metrics
when you're launching a game.
First, we have
first-time installers.
These are users who have
visited your listing
and are installing your
game for the first time.
The other new metric
is one day retention,
which are first-time installers
who have not uninstalled
your game in the first day.
So, they've continued to keep
your game more than 24 hours,
which is when we find is
the key time for retention.
Even cooler, both
of these metrics
are now reported in
hourly intervals.
So previously, you might have
had to wait 24 hours or more
in order to see the
most current results.
Now, you can see
them every hour.
You can also opt in to
receive email notifications
for when we think your
experiment is complete.
This will help you
to make decisions
more quickly so you can take
advantage of good changes
and avoid the bad ones
as quickly as possible.
Using store listing
experiments can
lead to great gains
in user acquisition,
such as hot head games.
You saw a 40% increase
in acquisition rate
simply by improving their icon.
Here are some tips
and tricks that you
should keep in mind when
you're making the most out
of the store
listing experiments.
So first of all, you
should think back
to how you were taught
experimentation in high school
science class.
To get the clearest results, you
should test just a single asset
at a time.
For example, changing your
icon or maybe a screenshot.
Because, if you change
too many things at once,
you won't actually know
what drove that change
in acquisition rate.
Second, you'll want to make sure
that you test for at least a
full week so that you can
track weekday and weekend
performance, because users
behave differently depending
on the time of the week.
For games, the most
prominent assets
are your icon
screenshots and videos.
So make sure to prioritize
these for testing.
Finally, when you have a variant
that we tell you is working,
you'll want to promote that
one to be your main listing as
soon as possible.
But, you should continue
serving your original
as a 1% experiment
for a few more weeks
so that you can
ensure that over time,
this new one is still
outperforming your old one.
Great.
So, once you've optimized
your store listing,
you now have a solid foundation
for user acquisition.
You've probably learned
a lot about your users
along the way and the
best ways to communicate
what's unique and
exciting about your game.
But, as you're looking at
your experiment results
and diving deeper into our
user acquisition reports,
you may find that there
are specific segments that
aren't converting as
well as you'd like.
Google Play enables you to
run this global business
and not all users are the same.
So, I'm excited to talk to you
about a powerful new feature
that allows you to market to
these different user segments
in a way that is much more
likely to get them to install
your game.
This is what we call
custom store listings.
Custom store listings
allow you to create
unique store listings delivered
to specific user segments.
So, you tell us which types of
users should see this listing.
And we do the rest.
So, let me walk you through some
of the new targeting criteria.
The first targeting dimension
that we've introduced
is country.
Up until now, you've
had to rely on language
as a rough proxy for geography.
But, users in
different countries
don't always choose the
language you would guess.
For example, did you know
that half of users in India,
over half of users in
India, have set their device
language to either American
or British English.
And these flavors of
language are not the same.
I know this firsthand.
So, I'm an American, born and
raised, but I live in London.
And if you've ever been
to London, if you ever
find yourself invited
to a fancy dress party,
you want to make sure that
you got the country right.
Because, if you
get it wrong, you
could end up wearing a
tuxedo to a costume party.
Or worse, show up wearing
a costume to something
like a wedding, or an
anniversary, or something
worse.
Who knows?
So, with this feature,
you can serve up
to five different listings to
completely different groups
of countries.
So, by first targeting
by geography,
you're very specific in how
you communicate to your users.
So, imagine you're
a soccer game.
Do you want your users
to be dreaming of being
in the most successful squad?
Or do you want them to be
part of the winning-est team
in the tables?
You can also use
your icon to help
users feel more at home,
such as the use of English
and American flags in
the icons we have here.
We're also adding other
targeting capabilities.
You can now target on the
launch day of your game,
for those of you that were
excited about pre-reg.
This is a really powerful way
to change your marketing message
to the right set of users
throughout the lifecycle
of your game.
So for example, for
pre-registration users,
you can now highlight rewards
or display a pre-launch teaser
trailer that the users in
places where you've launched
are not seeing so you can
really customize your message.
For example, Gamevil's
game, Talion,
was able to make use of
pre-registration store
listings.
So like most games, they didn't
launch everywhere at once.
Using this feature, they
were able to communicate
their launch only to the users
that were eligible for it.
And they basically doubled their
pre-registration conversion
rate.
Finally, taking a
step back, I want
to give you a peek behind
the curtain of what else
we're up to.
We're launching an early access
program for install state.
Today, when you think
about your store listing,
you're thinking about, how do I
get users to install the game?
But, some of these
visitors already
have your game installed.
Or worse, they've churned or
maybe uninstalled your game.
So, we can help you to
re-engage with these users,
such as in this example, where
we can communicate new game
play in order to bring these
users back and excite them
into reinstalling your game.
If you're interested in
being part of this beta that
we're running, be sure to go
to g.co/play/installstateEAP.
And we'll get you signed up.
All right.
So, I've just
spent a lot of time
talking to you about
the marketing message
that you provide.
But, there are other
parts of the store
listing that users see.
Specifically, I'm
talking about ratings.
Did you know that 42% of users
who leave a one star review
mentions stability or bugs?
No one in this room means
to have stability problems.
But, it's often hard to
measure and track them
so that you can fix them.
Luckily, we have
Android vitals to help
you gather more insight.
We offer 15 engineering
metrics across five
different performance areas
to represent the things
that users care about the most.
So, you can measure the
performance and quality
of your app as experienced
on real devices
in the hands of real
users in the real world.
So, if you're interested
in Android vitals,
be sure to join some of
these other talks that
are going on this week.
To wrap it all up,
custom store listings
for countries and
pre-registration
is available today, as are
the store listing experiments
for all of these store listings.
I hope I've inspired
you to think
about cool and unusual ways that
you might be able to segment
your audience to really
squeeze out as much
of the acquisition rate
as you possibly can.
Now, Andrew is going
to come up on stage
and walk you through building
an instant game, which
is a very important part
of any store listing,
but requires a little bit
more technical know how.
Thanks for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW GIUGLIANO: Thanks, Steve.
Hello, my name is
Andrew Giugliano.
And today, I will be talking to
you about Google Play Instant.
And to answer your
question, yes, I
got a really bad sunburn during
the keynote this morning.
It happens.
It happens to the best of us.
Google Play Instant
is a technology
that enables users to instantly
be immersed in your experience
with a single tap,
letting them try
your game without the
weight of installing.
Here, we see an
example of cookie jam
blast being launched
from the try now button
in the Play Store.
Today, instant games can
be launched from anywhere
across all of player's
properties and beyond.
Now, how does Google Play
Instant help your game?
Simply put, it is getting
players into your experience
fast.
It's increasing discoverability.
You're getting more players
into your experience
across many surfaces.
You're driving installs.
Players are given
the opportunity
to install your
game without ever
having to leave the experience.
And you're improving retention.
By offering players
a taste of your game,
Google Play Instant
helps players
feel more confident that your
game is worth installing.
And this could lead to
less players uninstalling
after download.
As you can see,
this technology has
been helpful to our partners.
Across different categories,
monetization strategies,
technologies, we've seen Instant
be impactful in driving uplift
for our developers.
If there's one key
takeaway from this slide,
it's that Instant could
be helpful for your game.
I also want to call out
our fantastic ecosystem
of developers that is
formed to help others
create their own Instant games.
In fact, AppOnboard,
just yesterday,
released their AppOnboard
Studio Tools, specifically built
for Instant games, which helps
creators create an Instant
game with no code.
I believe this is a
testament that we are not
alone in seeing the
potential of Instant games
to help developers
drive installs.
And we're not stopping there.
We will be continuing to
expand the reach of Instant.
You may have noticed a few
slides ago the game's playlist
that lets you try a
lot of games very fast.
That's on the far left.
And our success has enabled
us to elevate Instant games
from the store listing to
the top layer of Play Store
Discovery, from the
search page to game
highlights and collections
on the landing page.
These new experiences
were made possible
to the incredible
support of our partners
building instant games.
So now that we've seen
the impact of Instant,
we'll do a deep dive on
building your own instant game
from scratch.
Engineers in the room,
this pit will be for you.
Now, under the hood,
an instant game
is just a 10
megabyte or less APK
that is being served
over Play, downloaded,
and run on a more secure
runtime on the device.
Creating a separate APK and
getting under that size limit,
it might sound
difficult. But, here we
will show you how easy it is
to create your own instant game
and we'll give you all
the tools to do so.
In fact, if anything
is to be taken away
from the next section, it's
that creating instant games
is now easier than ever.
In this example,
we'll use Unity.
But, nearly any APK
can be made instant.
And we have a great plugin for
Coco's creators developers.
We'll see that later.
First off, there
are four major steps
in creating an instant game.
And this spans any game engine.
You're going to build it out.
So, you're going to actually
make the APK instant.
You're going to
gracefully convert
your users from the instant
game to the install game.
You're going to reduce size
to meet that 10 megabyte
requirement, and we'll give
you some tips and tricks
to do that.
And you're going to
do some publishing
and testing on Play to
test the distribution
of your instant game.
So let's build the instant game.
First off, the
tools we will need
is Unity, the great Google
Play Instant plug-in for Unity.
That will make a
lot of this easier.
You can get that
on the asset store.
You can also download
it on GitHub.
An Android device can
be physical or virtual.
We recommend testing it on
Pre-Oreo and Oreo plus devices,
just because there's a slight
difference in the runtime.
And access to your source code
and Play Developer Console.
First step, you'll go to the
build settings in the plugin.
You will choose the
scenes that you'd
like to include in
your instant game.
And that's it.
So, the URL is not required.
We provide a
default one any-who.
And don't worry
about asset bundles,
we'll see that a little later.
Next, you'll configure
your Player Settings.
This is a mix of
required changes
you need to make
your game instant.
It's all a click of a button,
you just click Update.
As well some recommended changes
to help reduce that size.
And then you just select
build and run from the plugin,
and you can run your
game instantly locally.
Super easy.
So now that we've
built an instant game,
let's gracefully convert those
users from the instant game
to the installed game.
Because, obviously, that's what
we're trying to do here, right?
That's the scope.
So, we make it easier by
providing a showInstallPrompt,
where you just call
one line of code,
we show the prompt, and
we care of the rest.
And it works for
pre-reg as well.
So, players can
pre-register and install
without ever having to leave
the instant experience.
Likely, you should put this
at the end of your experience
and have a level that match.
And you could also show
a persistent button
so the user could, at
any time, go to install.
Additionally, you might want
to carry some information over.
We'll show you that, too.
That could be buy in-game
items, levels, when
you customize your character.
You can use a cookie API
to transfer this data over.
So, here, you'll just
call the one line above.
And we will do the rest.
Likewise, you can just put
a string of data together
and we will bring that
over to the install game.
And this is all you
have to call to get
that data on the other side.
And just like that, you have all
the tools to convert your user
from instant to installed.
OK, let's look at reducing size.
This could be the
most frightening one
for some developers.
But, we'll give you some help.
First off, you want to narrow
the scope of the content
in your instant game.
You don't want to include your
full game as an instant game.
And if it's under 10 megabytes
already, that's great.
But, really you want to
offer a trailer of your game.
You want to offer the
most exciting pieces.
Show game play that is critical
to understanding the full game.
But, you shouldn't just
choose easy levels,
show the exciting ones as well.
And, again, games as
large as 350 megabytes
have been able to
launch instant games.
And I'm sure even
larger than that.
No matter what game you have,
you can create an instant game.
Remove unnecessary assets.
Do deep dive through
technical resources.
Remove what's not needed.
Unneeded assets.
Even reducing resolution.
Really, you should
ask yourself, is it
critical to get us
to the experience?
If not, remove it.
Also, follow those recommended
settings I showed you earlier.
That really helps
in reducing size.
Finally, a really good way
to get under that size limit
are asset bundles.
They allow you to load
assets dynamically
while the instant
game is running.
And these assets will not
count against your limit.
While you may use as many
asset bundles as you like,
each asset level must be less
than 50 megabytes in size.
So, be thoughtful on how many
asset bundles you import.
There are three pieces
needed to use asset bundles
in your instant game.
First, you want to
create asset bundles
from the scenes in your game.
You want to show user
friendly loading screen
while that is loading up.
And you will need
a web server CDN
to serve these asset bundles.
And using the tool
in the plugin,
we will help you take
care of those first two.
So, first, you'll go to
the bundle creation tab
and you'll select the
scenes that you want
include in the asset bundle.
Once finished, we will give
you a file that you'll throw up
on your web server or CDN.
And then that next
screen, you'll
specify the URL to
access those files.
Additionally, you can
provide a custom background
for the loading screen I
was talking about earlier.
But, we provide a
default one as well.
So, super easy.
And just like that,
when you click Finish,
we will generate the code
to retrieve the asset
bundles in the game.
So, it's really easy
and you're all set.
So we've looked at some
tools for reducing size.
Let's look at Play
and how Play can
help in this testing in
the development phase.
You should take
your instant game
and you should upload it to
your internal test track.
There's no size limit here.
So, you can use this
iteratively while you're
building this instant game
to test the distribution up
to 100 users that
you'll choose manually.
Now, make sure that there is
an accompanying installable
listing or you're
in pre-reg phase.
Because, you need to
upgrade to installed or you
need to be in the pre-reg phase.
And then, of course, push your
production when you're ready.
And just like that,
you have all the tools
to make a production-ready
instant game.
You can see more information
below at the link.
Not using Unity?
No problem.
Make the following changes
in your manifest to make
nearly any APK locally
readable as instant.
And, of course, you'll need
to follow the four key steps.
We talked about
some APIs earlier.
If you follow the
GitHub link, you'll
see some sample code
and native Android
for using the same
APIs, like cookie, API,
and a showInstallPrompt.
We also offer a plugin
with Cocos Creator
that allows you to create
an instant game by recording
the game play.
And I'll show you the
assets needed to package it
with your instant game.
It's a really cool experience.
So, to quickly recap,
there are three key things
I want you to walk away with.
Number one, that Play
offers an incredible array
of promotional and
marketing tools
from pre-reg, to store
listing experiments, to Google
Play instant.
Two, these tools
are easy to use.
Most are configurable
through the Play Console.
And in the case of
Google Play Instant,
we showed you that you could
build a demo yourself or have
one of our implementation
partners build one for you.
Lastly, Play's
promotional capabilities
can deliver material
business impact.
So, what's next?
You can start by taking a
picture of this slide, which
includes all the links
from the presentations.
Phones are going up.
Now that we've taken a look
at what instant games are,
how they can help, and
how to build your own,
I want to give you
a chance to test
some of the instant games
that are out there today.
Scan the QR code and
you'll be brought
to a collection of great
instant games on the Play Store.
At the bottom, here
is the link to sign up
for the customized
store listing features
and install state EAP as well.
So, with that, thank
you for your time.
Enjoy the rest of your evening.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]